from funny moments to hype plays we've
rounded up some of the best community
clips to get your week started off right
featuring call of duty war zone cold war
and a whole lot more
if you want to figure out how you can
submit your own clips for next week then
stay tuned to the end of the video
in the meantime leave a like subscribe
and get ready for the ride
with the same one oh my gosh that was
going for the same helicopter oh
who's gonna get there first oh my god
they're both going for it who gets their
first i mean you send all four players
essentially
first yep there it is gets it straight
away
you can see the disappointment on the
face of pawneehoff
no helicopter in the bottom left though
there's a kill already in the bottom
left that's god he's already picked up
one
now he's looking for it oh my goodness
isaac's found one rockets found the
actual kill he's cleaned that up they
need one more
they need one there it
what a is to end game mode
[Music]
[Music]
overhead
oh
now i respect that i i think i i think
i'd leave too if that was my first
aid jet i swirled my man
[Music]
are you safe
right here
enemies
[Music]
incoming
[Music]
domination
oh my god
hmm
[Music]
hey uh you guys sniping have uh
silencers on these snipers right
now of course my launcher's got a sniper
on it
oh here comes another holy oh my god
[Music]
this could not have went worse for
dealio and muskin really
oh god
oh god what a clash from deleo
foreign
equally
least 20 kills so far
[Music]
this is the cheater this is him never
mind
on this tree look at me
well this is this this is cheater this
is cheater yep they're a hundred percent
cheating i just got beamed
okay so there's they don't want to like
pop up and just get one side shot do you
guys know where the other angle is
that's on the half wall okay this one is
on the half wall like right here
left of that actually right here i'm
getting wobbling before i peek
okay we can probably deal with one at a
time
yeah i'm gonna see if i can
you know he'll beat you
there's one guy direct east direct east
on the road dab if you pick that he's
gonna beat me
i'm gonna go through firehouse and i'm
gonna challenge them right now just got
one of them got one got one of them
hang on we're gonna help scale we gotta
help scout right now he's looking at me
he's looking at me right now
stunning no hit no hit
he's seventy seven three two three
help me 20 seconds cut the wire
exactly when i say not before ready
green wire 20 seconds
green wire in three two
one time in three
two one cut green next
yellow in two twenty seconds
cut the wire exactly when i say not
before
ready green wire
20 seconds green next yellow done
last one is red there are two reds the
top one
in two one
here thank you so much for watching and
if you've made it to this point in the
video then i'm pretty sure
you want to know how to submit your own
clips it's actually pretty easy
all you got to do is tag me on twitter
at persia underscore xo or
at gamespot and we can take a look keep
in mind it doesn't have to just be call
of duty it could be any game we're
looking forward to seeing it all
alright leave a like subscribe and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you